well for nick
his first career start against his old
team so you know that's a big day
bounding ball the devers has been so
sharp defensively
on the money and one out
hit toward the shift charging in arroyo
he'll flip quickly got him on a bang
bang play
kenzler gets the nod well phillies were
ready to start the tough right-hander
aaron nola today but he is on that
coveted watch
ground ball over to third roddy thereas
is up with it
and one out
two two pitch coming
check swing
and kinsler sinker ball pitcher wants
ground balls he got two of them
including that one
one two cut on and missed that was nasty
struck him out first k in the book for
nick pavetta
and a 2-2 home
and that's gonna be in there for strike
three hoskins didn't like it but the
curve ball on the edge struck him out
xander 322 with 14 home runs
tallied his 50th run batted in yesterday
and headed for denver today
there's a shot high and deep kissing
goodbye gone right now
home runs xander bogarts 15 for the
x-man
15 and 51 sounds even better that was
instantaneous
and the red sox grab a one-nothing lead
over the phillies
new pitcher is christopher sanchez just
called up today from the minor leagues
he's a 24 year old from the dominican
republic he's been up to the major
league club couple times this season a
little trickler up the middle and that's
a seeing eye base hit
rafael devers on right after the home
run by the x-man 0-2 pitch coming to him
bouncer over the mound gregorius has it
throws on the run in time
well that is a very upset marlin
gonzalez who's just back after a
hamstring injury but he is now out of
the ball game after running to first
base bobby daubic is going to take over
for him as the first baseman take a look
unfortunate right here as he hits the
first base and you'll see him just kind
of you know go across that back and pull
up just before he gets to the bag and
re-injure it apparently and
that's frustrating you just get back in
the lineup and off you go again
unfortunately you'll have a few days off
but
boy those hamstrings they are tough they
can hang on for a long time
[Music]
over to third off the glove of divers
and down the left field line bogarts is
able to track it down and te reyes will
put the brakes on smartly
and that'll be the first hit for the
fills
and a curve ball high ball four and that
puts two on with one out well now it's
up to jt real muto with two outs and
runners on first and second
opposite way there's a base hit it to
right field tyres is around third
heading for home he's gonna wind up
scoring the throw goes toward third
jankowski slides it head first the ball
goes into the dugout he'll come home to
score and the phillies take the lead
hammered oh what a play by dolbeck he's
up foot race to the bag he got him
pavetta
he got to first base in time
shot through the hole in a base hit
arroyo on to begin the third inning the
lanky lefty little dribbler here
sanchez gloves and fires high took him
off the bag and everybody's safe
bouncer second base could be two there's
one and two that's a huge play
[Music]
swing and a miss he got him
and no damage done
and reese lines that breaking ball out
toward left for dugo dives he can't get
it it gets by him and reese is on his
way to second and he'll get there
standing
with a two-out double
ball four so brad miller walks
two on with two outs
and thereas who reached on the single
off the third base bag as last time is
coming up here
there's a high fly ball to left field
verdugo will just stand and watch it is
long gone
into the back row of the monster seats
ronald thereas a three-run home run and
the phillies lead it five to one
stepping up
tears into this one another play by
dalbeck again to pavetta and in time boy
he's made a couple of brilliant plays
yaksel rios to make an appearance so a
short start for nick pavetta
driven into right center hernandez
common common diving and made the play
and now he's going to throw back into
first base and that's going to be a
double play
segura still doesn't realize that [ __ ]
caught that ball yeah he's standing at
third in wonder
but [ __ ]
laying out and making a sensational
diving play
sock toward the alley long run here by
jankowski that's sailing and it is off
the wall
arroyo charging into second base in a
pull-up with a double and he almost
powered it out of here right up against
the bullpen fence
hector narrows to the hill and he's
averaging over 11 strikeouts per nine so
now verdugo trying to pick him up alex
today over two last time up hit into a
463 double play
pounding ball toward the hole segura
will spin and throw as the run comes in
to score
so the red sox do get this second run
finally it is five to two that is the
100th career rbi for alex fordugo
high fly ball hit it for the wall that's
up there
off the monster
back to mccutcheon jd wants two the
throw the tag safe he got in there
martinez with a double
that's 28 straight games he's been on
base
hammered in the center field hernandez
again with a dive tk did it again
boy is he having some season in the
outfield how about this show
[Applause]
this is unreal
that one's crunched in the left center
for a base hit on a red pro aboard his
first hit today
3-2 that one driven toward the wall
rising up high off the monster
renfro heading into third into second a
big turn
vasquez went too far
he's caught in a rundown renfro holding
at third base and they will get vasquez
who went too far
pounding ball deep short gregorius from
the grass skips it in a wild throw
and a run is in
that'll make it 5-3
two-run game here's arroyo
two down a man aboard
and that one is a gap shot that's on the
grass to the track and up against the
wall
here comes bobby d rounding third
he's trying to score and he will without
a throw
and it's a one-run game at fenway
with the elements the 3-2 pitch
a little trickler here on amino to
pounce on that oh look at that play
fires it away though
heading into second now heading back to
first here's the throw the tag and he's
back in well that was a crazy play yeah
what was adam doing
did he go between the legs i thought he
did i thought he did yes basketball
and that's gonna be strike three
ranger suarez the very tough lefty and
there's a shot to center field down for
a base hit and a good start for the sox
here in the eighth inning the lead off
man is on
crowd demanding a hit 3-2
and he walked him got the fastball in
3-2 again and he walked him
and the bases are loaded for the red sox
in the eighth inning
and the pitch to him fastball bounced on
the ground towards second segura's got
it throws to first in time and the
inning is over suarez peers in and gets
the sign the one-two pitch grounded to
the right side picked up by hoskins
flipped over to suarez steps on the bag
and that'll do it and the phil's win it
and what a job by ranger suarez as he
locks it down for the phillies he gets
the final seven outs of this one and
holds on to a one run lead